Film Courage: What are 5 things a writer should
know about the TV writing room?
Jeffrey Davis: You take 2 and a half and I’ll
take 2 and a half.
Peter Desberg: [Laughs]
Jeffrey Davis: Go ahead…want me to start?
Peter Desberg: Yeah.
Go ahead.
Jeffrey Davis: Know that to get in you’ve
got to…90 percent chance you are going to
have to work your way into the room as script
assistant, as a writer’s assistant.
Those jobs are plentiful and great and you
will get training.
Know that it will take awhile.
Also know that when you are a baby writer…don’t
talk, listen.
No one likes someone who answers questions.
Know that people are good at one or two things
but no one is good at everything.
I think I answered three that leaves you two.
Peter Desberg: And don’t be the smartest
person in the room.
Ever, ever…
Jeffrey Davis: Never be the smartest person
in the room.
Film Courage: Why?
Peter Desberg: Because everybody will hate
you…
Jeffrey Davis: Especially the show runner.
Peter Desberg: And you won’t be the smartest
person in the room and everyone will see that.
And really, you cannot be full of yourself.
Jeffrey Davis: I’m not going to mention
the show.
I will mention that it was my friend Bob who
was very close to as I said Chuck Lurie (who
gave Chuck Lurie his break).
And Chuck will call Bob every once in awhile
even though Bob is semi-retired and say “I
really need help” and it was a point a of
couple years ago when he had five shows on
the air.
And he went on one of the shows and he pitched
a joke and he said to Bob “Was that funny?
When you were working on My Two Dads, was
that funny back then?
Or on Facts of Life?”
And Chuck went to Bob and said “Look, I
don’t need the money.
I’m out of here.”
And he left.
If you’re a show runner, the best show runner
you can be is the kind of person who mentors
other people.
Who is secure enough (like Phil Rosenthal)
to really care about getting the best out
of people.
That’s the best kind of leader.
Peter Desberg: We had [in Peter and Jeffrey’s
new book Now That’s Funny) a lot of great
stories about rooms and show runners.
And Peter Casey was great.
He said “I worked on The Jeffersons.
And I came to the room late one day.
And I hadn’t eaten breakfast.
And I brought a little box of Corn Flakes
with me.
And I went to the corner where the coffee
was, poured it in and took a little of the
cream and poured it on there.
And the guy said ‘That’s not for your
cereal.
That’s for the coffee!”
And he charged him like 25 cents for doing
that.
Film Courage: Oh…my!
Peter Desberg: And they would feed us the
worst food ever.
He said when I went to work on Cheers with
The Charles Brothers, they would take us out
to really good restaurants or if they had
to work late they’d call up one of the really
good restaurants and we’d order from the
menu and they would deliver it.
They said they treated the writers with so
much kindness and respect and they got such
great work out of us.
Nobody complained if it was late.
Where with The Jeffersons everybody was grumbling
all the time and hated being in the room.
So he said that The Charles Brothers made
us purr like kittens.
Jeffrey Davis: I don’t think he actually
said that.
Peter Desberg: Alright, I am taking license.
Film Courage: Was there another because I
think you only got one in?
Jeffrey Davis: No that’s four altogether.
Film Courage: Four?
Five total…
Peter Desberg: Be careful!
Film Courage: Be careful.
Okay.
Know where the exit is?
Jeffrey Davis: This is sort of repetitious
but I think it bears repeating.
It’s really important that when you get
into a room you use it as a learning experience
because you are one of the very few people.
When I started there was still a freelance
market.
There really is no freelance market anymore
and so if you have the luck to get into a
room take advantage of it and be humble and
Peter’s right…
Peter Desberg: But I will add a fifth just
for the sake of completeness that every room
has a culture…
Jeffrey Davis: Oh…that’s true.
Peter Desberg: And you want to spend a lot
of time observing before you jump in and just
because one person makes a joke doesn’t
mean everybody makes jokes and if one person
kids another person that doesn’t mean that
everybody teases and you want to wait and
when you really understand how people interact,
then you slowly test the waters and start
to do it.
Even then…you do it slowly.
Jeffrey Davis: My two wonderful former students
who are on One Day at a Time were on the show
(now they are on their second season).
They are not the baby writers anymore.
You see how that works?
So they were on the show, they were on like
three months, they were on like show seven
or eight.
And they hadn’t said that much.
I mean they’ve done their work, they were
the first script their mentor wrote with them
(so it was the three of them writing it) which
was really generous of her (that doesn’t
always happen).
And they didn’t say anything one day and
one of the writers said “Caroline, we’d
really like to hear what you guys think.
You guys are one of these character’s age.”
Opening and yet she began by the “What if”
thing.
So that left room to be wrong if they didn’t
like what she said.
And after that day they were like “You guys
should…whenever you have something to say,
say it.
Don’t be shy.”
But they were smart to wait because they were
learning, they were observing and they were
only 25-years-old.
That’s young to be in a room.
And they didn’t think the show was going
to get a second season.
And now it’s big heads, it’s Emmy-nominated
and it’s a big hit.
Peter Desberg: By the way, you tricked us.
You said only three more questions and the
first one is a five-parter.
Don’t think that went past us.
Jeffrey Davis: It went past me.
You make her laugh.
Peter Desberg: She has a low-threshold.